zack snyder has a tweet here it says
amazing character you created
honored to have our worlds collide at
david air movies at geraldo okay let's
go to david ayers he did respond oh
you set the tone for creativity and
freedom
thank you damn right he did that's right
warrior brothers was like nope no we are
not around here
we made a big mistake when we touted her
no no no no no no
what is going on reject nation well
i got some messages on social media greg
did you check out the zack snyder photo
of jared johnson of jared leto
that's joker
they just see it they just see it and i
thought
no no there's not a camera pointed at me
second i saw like a little thumbnail pop
up on the youtube notifications i was
let's see what's going on here let's see
all right zack snyder's page
oh wow so it's not a clear photo of him
no he's got a glove on which i'm
assuming is purple
it looks like a it literally looks like
that like literally
yeah it actually looks like arthur fleck
it does it looks like he has a
different hairdo at the very least yeah
it looks like he's got some kind of
stringy sort of jaw length hair
he said that it was going to be like an
apocalyptic joker
and that joker card is what's featured
in the snyder cut trailer
this is the origin of how that card got
burnt into rubble
or maybe it's the moments right before
because the card's like flying around in
the debris and stuff
so maybe this is right before all this
happens maybe it's right before some
kind of crazy maneuver by
apocalyptic joker i wonder where this is
he's he being held captive or is he
experimenting on people during this
apocalyptic times just through the
blurred image
it feels like he's still in like some
type of arkham setting no yeah
he's got some type of white straight
yeah yeah yeah like
and i'm sure that they partly did this
they'd release this super deep focused
image so that we could all speculate
like idiots about yeah
what is this shirt yeah is it the white
blazer or something like that or is he
in yeah is he an arkham and then what is
this is
blood marks on the photo too and the
card looks like it try to break down
every little image man how many are
there can we connect them into yeah
batman's blood and is that robin's blood
and this like plaid lattice uh uh
pattern in the background what does that
mean even though his face is
really blurred there's something that
looks somewhat disfigured about his face
looks monstrous and and like his
forehead looks like it goes really
far up too so it gives him this weird
like almost ball
yeah he looks like a balding warped
clown you know what he kind of looks
like it looks like a combination of two
things
the way how and i'll throw a photo up
here the way
how cameron monahan looked at the end of
gotham spoilers for all you people who
don't care to watch gotham and it also
kind of looks like one of the prometheus
monsters
yeah it's like the engineers hey maybe
you know what that's what zack snyder's
gonna do he's gonna bring in every
director who had a movie that was like
hugely anticipated and then went wrong
and he's just gonna make
it all right right here and so we'll
find out that the joker is one of the
engineers he helped create mankind
thus imbuing us with the spirit of chaos
well i wonder if he
is possibly pulling from the storyline
in the new 52
there's a storyline where joker did like
cut off and take off his face and gotham
did
actually uh have some fun with that too
with the first interpretation that
cameron monahan was doing as joker
because of the fact of how there's
something that seems off about the shape
of his face because yes it's a very
blurred image and maybe it all can be
chalked up to that maybe zack snyder did
more post altering just to mess with us
a little bit more he does look like
either he
did something happening maybe survive
some type of nuclear waste maybe he is
pulling from the thing of like cutting
off his face and reattaching it
you know or maybe he's just all bandaged
up or something yeah it feels like some
type of disfigured thing is going on
absolutely it's it's got
a jarring uncanny valley that makes it
almost disturbing to look at
you know what's fascinating about this
photo and this might seem like just a
little thing
is that you know how he releases these
black and white photos and zack snyder
has talked about potentially wanting to
release like a black and white cut all
the photos that have come out i felt
like converted to black and white
this feels like something that could be
a black and white scene
it does because like especially with how
out of focus it is you would really need
to be gearing the
tones correctly and i mean not that you
can't do that in post or with color
correction and not that there aren't
some sharp lines on it but yeah it does
seem like you would need to
fine-tune it for those tones there's a
lot when you add color and a lot gets
lost
in that when you convert it to black and
white so i wouldn't be surprised at all
if this was meant to be that way
i love how it's a bird everyone's
it's a cool photo but it looks if you
were to tell me this is a joker photo
i would think like oh man they're
actually making arthur fleck arc into
the actual joker here
and then oh it's a snyder guy jared leto
photo well yeah and he does look
monstrous which i mean for either
version
of the joker whether it be arthur fleck
or you know more
jared leto it still looks like a really
cool turn for the character and so for
jared leto this could improve upon what
people didn't like so much last time
oh and this is so cool to see how much
like zack snyder and david air support
each other i know
them just you know they have been in the
same doodling each other on twitter all
the time
we're we kind of slided by this whole
process i'm someone who's also been
championing for releasing the air cut as
well
i feel like it all rides on the success
of the snyder cut i really hope he can
make it happen
well i think that would jared leto if
this is just even a scene
that is really good yeah i think it can
be enough to turn people around
one scene can do wonders when you say it
out loud you might be like it's just one
scene
i think a powerful enough moment
freaking blade runner 2049 convinced me
that dave bautista is this amazing actor
he's like an incredible dramatic one you
know that's a very memorable moment
i was like yeah he's funny in guardians
but man is he incredible dramatic actor
like brooding yeah like guy who only
fights when he has to
i think this could probably turn it
around and i think this could aid in
getting the air cut done especially the
fact that jared leto's joker is
supposed to be incredibly more prominent
in david ayers movie yeah so i'd be
excited to see what kind of ripple
effect
this actually evolves into you know yeah
you know what i'm saying
i know exactly what i'm saying i'm
picking up what you're putting down
zack snyder did release like some other
image as i'm scrolling through his
twitter like other images that we did
not talk about he had this one here of
gal gadot his hashtag snydercut in the
theaters
is this his editing room is that the
imax universal look at that rail i've
heard people test movies there i mean
that looks like an imax i mean that's
in la that's the spot to go to watch
imac's movies absolutely that's my
favorite spot i don't know what this
means
i'm going to run this on imax to make
sure it's good for hbo max
right it's going to be hbo imax next
let's
if you have a good enough tv of all that
extra resolution true
that's true here's a photo of whoa
martian man hunter
there's a war coming martian man hunter
is that that's cyborg that's ray fisher
covering up after
yeah sure looks like walter hamada got
mad
i gotta cover my face we got a stunt
double what's your hamada can't know i'm
promoting this movie
cyborg is gonna be in the movie with no
lines
just that mask on the whole time and he
does have this photo here though
of uh the film reel that's gonna be the
opening of the movie yeah it's gonna
someone goes down
picks up the film reel hey what's this
justice league wait there's more dust
this could save the world
this is a sneaker cut the first the
prologue is just somebody loading it
into the frame and then projecting it
right onto your
this actually out of all the photos this
one has the most meaning
i mean beautiful photo it really is like
the snider name and color and it's
crossed out
this is surreal i know it's happening
what do you think about this
photo of jared leto as joker any
theories or thoughts that pop into mind
are you excited for him to get a second
chance leave your thoughts down below
subscribe
click that notification bell and hey
we'll see
[Music]
you